cowman whoo lives in a storage depot in
the Paris suburbs of Oba Villa a he
doesn't usually talk to journalists but
agreed to do so in the presence of two
members of the Association of Chinese
immigrants in France he claims that a
group of North African youths attacked
him in his home in November they took a
knife and tried to break open the door
well casi la photofit who tried to
resist and incurred a severe head injury
all the rent money for this
accommodation block and all cell phones
were stolen whose wife has since gone to
live with relatives
how do you feel now so much alpha time
within you I'm scared I don't feel safe
anymore police registered almost 200
muggings and attacks on the ethnic
Chinese community of over Vili a last
year many were reportedly committed by
criminal gangs often of North African
origin some locals openly voice their
prejudices that's the way it is I don't
like the Chinese I don't know why but i
dont metion want me to see the chinese
and become too rich in france
- rich know what and that's not fair
just me I think it's not fair they're
now in the category of people with nice
clothes and big cars Bella peed the bed
watch you the 70,000 strong ethnic
Chinese community in France has earned a
reputation for being hardworking and
discreet the North African communities
are considered to be less successful as
a whole nickel now something new is
happening and it's linked to a
competitive ideology that's beginning to
appear the Chinese are considered to be
a community where things go well where
people manage on their own and are
quieter or compared to other immigrants
who are much more demanding and consider
themselves as victims and might consider
this Chinese community as competition
Kimiko POC salsa brought up the Chinese
textile industry in Oba Valley a has
grown massively over the past 20 years
and more and more immigrants have come
from China to make a better living for
themselves in France
[Music]
we we used to teach geography in China
and is a pillar of the Chinese community
here
he feels let down by the police
beautiful things are far apart my French
isn't that good argument so the police
just didn't believe me quick learn what
I thought Honda hmm told you those young
North Africans just claimed that there
was a fight between all the people who
live here the Madonna
so the but that's just not true at all
the authorities have come under fire for
not paying enough attention to
inter-communal strife in the suburbs
some sociologists blame the lack of
interest on a larger political
calculation the ethnic Chinese community
tends to vote on the right whereas the
north african community is more likely
to vote left
c'mon if I said ago we're faced with
groups that are more and more shaping
themselves in terms of identity
especially when it comes to our first
community which we call Muslim in
inverted commas that's the way the state
identifies and describes it and this
encourages preferential treatment
acquire ID not in the logic the Coyotes
SEO there is a suspicion that the
authorities passive attitude has led to
an increase in attacks on the ethnic
Chinese community last summer a man died
five days after being mugged
Evon son president of the Chinese
Association has been trying to persuade
families to overcome their shame and to
report attacks a group of youths mug
this girl and threatened her with a
knife silhouette for some she opposed I
think the law has to be changed the
police has to carry out its work for all
right but school it's very late listen
the police do a lot of work in our
offices you know he let me spend a lot
of time on reports complaints possible
put
planta woo is still waiting for
compensation and for his attackers to be
put on trial it could be a long wait